so when you're looking at properties to
buy like develop like this for instance
this is on the market right now for sale
how do you work out how much to buy a
property for how do you work out how
much to put down as your offer and the
answer is real simple all you do you
need to work backwards so the first
thing is how much is this property going
to be worth once you've done it up so
this probably needs knocking down build
something new Okay cool so if you knock
this down and build something no if you
buil a house how much would a house be
worth here maybe be worth a million
pound all right cool now you work
backwards well how much is it going to
cost to build or maybe it's going to
cost £300,000 to build cool 700 Grand
how much profit do you need to make well
you need to make 25% of the growth
development value which is 250 Grand
cool minus 250 Grand off of your 700
Grand that leaves you with 450 which is
how much you can buy it for